talking about bro signs what's your
thoughts on nofap ah I think that it is
it depends what you are doing it for are
you doing it because you've been told by
I know some like incel Forum that this
is like what you got to do or are you
doing it for uh dopamine detox thing are
you doing it like in what context just
in general what do I think about it yeah
and what are the contexts in which you
think it's got some efficacy and which
are the ones that you think is pie in
the sky I think there are a lot of
people who are sedentary hermit that
basically never leave their house and
use Outlets like pornography to achieve
that dopamine hit that is otherwise a
lower barrier to entry way of achieving
that smashing the dopamine button is a
lot higher effort to go find a woman you
know go on a date with her uh you know
attract her get her into your bed you
know have sexual intercourse and
actually put energy expenditure into
that activity as well it's very easy to
sit at your computer that you're already
at open up the browser and smash the
dopamine button so a lot of people just
it's almost like uh weirdly
paralleled version of those rat studies
where they just wired their brands and
then give them the opportunity to smash
this this dopamine button essentially
and they always choose to smash it over
and over again
it's like that is very much paralleled I
think in a lot of
um men nowadays because it's just such a
ease of access now that there is nothing
to dissuade them from doing it and not
having the I don't know the willpower or
the even want to try and avoid it to go
seek you know a higher quality of life
that might otherwise involve
companionship or whatever it is they
very much will take the easy route and
you know it still achieves the same
dopamine hit to them so for them it's
their there's wired to be you know for
them I think nofap could be useful
because at some point your biological
urges will be like get the [ __ ] out
there and have sex because you're
motivated so much just by frustration
yeah like the apathy and the complacency
that you have after busting a nut it's
just like you just don't really care
about anything you know
like why like why mightn't go find a
woman to be with when I'm satisfied and
I just feel fine you know I'm just
chilling here I don't need to do that so
that's where it would be useful yeah was
it not useful I think it's useful in
individuals who it has actually had a
detriment to their quality of life from
a relationship standpoint uh social
interaction standpoint some people end
up hindering the relationship quality
with their girlfriend too because
they're so porn addicted they end up you
know over masturbating and then exposing
themselves to stimuli that otherwise
makes them relatively unresponsive in an
actual real life setting with a woman I
think there are many scenarios in which
I think nofap or more specifically no
porn
potentially coupled with some degree of
nofap is worthwhile I think these get
conflated a lot is the nofap no porn
thing like a lot of people just say
nofap but in reality a lot of it is
problematic with the compounding effect
of the pornography exposure because if
you're just if you're just like thinking
about your girlfriend you bust a nut
because you haven't seen her in you know
a while I don't think that's bad
necessarily what else are you gonna do
you know so it's the pornography and
like tying that that the dopamine hit to
that activity that is overly problematic
and then the nofap if it gets if it's
excessive fapping or it's hindering your
drive to go do things in life that's a
logical fapping yeah yeah like at that
point when you can actually sit down and
objectively look at yourself and say
this is impeding my ability to either
get high quality relationships maintain
them in some capacity or it's not
leading to what I feel to be a high
quality of life in general like at that
point I think think nofap is absolutely
worth trying I think there's definitely
a a lower ceiling for where it's
Justified to do no porn versus I think
no fap like not I don't necessarily
think nofap needs to even be in the same
conversation as no porn always which it
often is people just assume it to be one
in the same yeah it's kind of branding
no pulling's got a branding problem
because it's not as catchy yeah no flaps
quite catchy and I don't think even with
porn I don't think it has a zero place
like I think there are some scenarios in
which you know could be great maybe it
excites your sex life who knows it's
just a matter of like the exposure like
too much or too little too much of
something is always bad in general so as
you would expect at some point you are
crossing the threshold into impeding
your quality of life in some capacity
I've read about risks online of going
too long without coming for men
any truth to that at all it's uh there
was this one study I dug into it was
about
ejaculation frequency and there was a
pretty clear Trend whereby after a week
if you don't bust a nut you will have a
big spike in testosterone and then
thereafter you end up having this
plateau effect where it doesn't stay
high it kind of like dips back down and
then plateaus
at Baseline so I think there's some sort
of biological like Rhythm to trying to
drive you to do something and then it's
almost like with with fasting if people
fast the first few days you're super
hungry you have these biological urges
to go eat and get nutrients and then
your body sort of shifts into like a
anti-catabolic more like sustained just
preserve yourself hibernation mode and I
think that very much applies to
ejaculation and sexual activity too like
if you go too long without it your body
goes into a state of like seemingly
adjusting to no sexual activity to some
extent I am no longer a reproductive
being yeah like I am maybe I'm
ancestrally I am uh out on a hunt or I'm
lost somewhere or I'm at war or
something and I need to just not be too
concerned about this so with that if
that was the case and if this study was
to be believed and there's probably
other factors in blah blah but that
would suggest that around about a weekly
to uh fortnightly Cadence of either
having sex so fapping yeah would
actually be an advantage because I'm
going to guess you only get this Spike
once it's not like if you weren't to
bust a nut again for the remainder of
that month you're not going to get
weekly spikes each time you get one and
then it plateaus so yeah repeat the
cycle if you ejaculate that one weekend
then you reset the clock every time yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it's it again like I
don't necess this would be like a wild
biohack to try and just recommend and I
don't necessarily like make sure you
only bust once a week not saying that
yeah it's just if you're somebody who is
to actually follow like what happens
biologically that seems to be in line
with what happens and a lot of people on
that do know fap they will also find
that it's extremely difficult at the
beginning and then after a while it's
like oh it's not that bad anymore and is
that maybe something that you actually
want to be adapted for yeah is actually
something that's so interesting like do
you want to be in a state of for example
Perpetual fasting where you just don't
desire nutrients like maybe maybe if
you're a bear who's hibernating like I
don't know but yeah well
um I was talking to Hamza who is kind of
my window into the younger guy's
personal development world and he was
saying that there's a lot of guys that
he knows who have attached their sense
of self-worth to the number of days
since they last fapped yeah there's
definitely something to be said about
the feeling like you're working towards
something and achieving something and
have power over your
your urges like you have a control over
your body because you definitely feel
like after you break a nofap streak
because you succumb to the urges you
feel like a piece of [ __ ] even though it
felt good for a second God damn it I
just I just [ __ ] up and the people who
are able to sustain and you know work
past that there's very much like a an
achievement of oh I've gone 27 days
without fapping or busting and I I'm you
know this is fantastic I have what's
Jerry Seinfeld say or uh George it's
like power over my domain or something
or I control my domain I forget what
they said but it's uh definitely
something to be said about the uh
um I don't know restraining definitely
giving guys a sense of reward for an
achievement of control of self not
giving in to urges like the same way you
would not give into you know craving
sugar or something and you feel good
about it I think some guys do would
expectually tie their self-worth uh you
know I don't need sex I don't go I can
go this long without even feeling like I
need and it could sometimes extend into
a problematic thing where it's like I
don't even need a woman like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] the other gender like I don't I
don't even need to have a companion
because I'm like that much of a lone
wolf who doesn't need to fap I don't
need a moment mode for the rest of my
life yeah what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]